bitte tragen sie vor allem an vollen und
geschlossenen orten ihre maske vorteil
für die abstand unterwegs mit einer
polizeistreife im istanbuler bezirk
schicht es ist samstag an wochenenden
herrscht ausgangssperre erlaubt es nur
der gang zum einkaufen im supermarkt wer
öffentliche verkehrsmittel benutzt oder
mit dem auto fährt braucht eine
sondergenehmigung in diesem wagen sitzen
fünf leute eng beieinander dass allein
gäbe bereits ein bußgeld es sind
studenten sie haben keine
sondergenehmigung wollen nach bossa alt
bist du 24 und du hast nicht in den
nachrichten gehört dass der verkehr
zwischen den städten am wochenende
verboten ist
sie werden einen strafbescheid bekommen
wegen verstoßes gegen die ausgangssperre
400 euro bußgeld pro person im park der
demokratie ist die freiheit ebenfalls
eingeschränkt erlaubt ist am wochenende
nur hunde in direkter umgebung der
wohnung gassi zu führen viele gehen
trotzdem spazieren fühlen sich
unbeobachtet tragen keine maske
doch die staatsmacht sieht fast alles
touristen dagegen dürfen sich frei
bewegen diese familie lebt in england
und verbringt den urlaub in istanbul
ich finde die beschränkungen richtig
natürlich geht es uns allen auf die
nerven aber es hilft ja nichts
das virus ist halt realität und bei der
jagd auf das virus setzt der türkische
staat auf digitale vernetzung und
überwachung wird zum beispiel ein
einkaufszentrum betreten will muss eine
corona app auf dem handy installiert
haben mit dem persönlichen sogenannten
hess code darunter gespeichert sind name
alter ausweisnummer außerdem die
telefonnummer für die kontakt verfolgung
[Musik]
ich fühle mich sicher aber es kann leute
geben die den hess code von jemand
anderem benutzen
wie genau das system ist das kann ich
natürlich nicht wissen aber
grundsätzlich finde ich die idee ganz
gut
ein anderes beispiel an einem nachmittag
klingen zwei vermummte an john alltours
haustür im istanbuler stadtbezirk asi
ausmann fascher es sind mitarbeiter des
örtlichen gesundheitsamt gestern abend
sagte meiner tochter ihre nase sei
verstopft sie können nicht riechen und
nicht schmecken
heute morgen sind wir ins staatliche
krankenhaus haben einen test gemacht
mittags haben sie uns angerufen und
sagten das ergebnis ist positiv
zwischen anrufe und hausbesuch liegen
nur wenige stunden
auch die mutter wird getestet die
kontakte der letzten tage abgefragt nach
jedem besuch wird die schutzkleidung
gewechselt 30 solcher mobilen teams sind
allein im bezirk da sie aus man pascha
unterwegs wenn sie uns eine person
meldet zu der sie kontakt hatte tragen
wir die sofort in das system des
gesundheitsministeriums allen liegt
diese person innerhalb unserer
bezirksgrenzen werden wie auch bei ihr
sofort einen hausbesuch sie machen tests
bringen medikamente führen impfungen zu
hause durch bei wind und wetter für junk
iran leitet das gesundheitsamt ist
zuständig für 600.000 einwohner im
stadtbezirk seit fast einem jahr arbeit
mir am anschlag sagt sie sie koordiniert
ihre teams mit hilfe einer riesigen
zentraldatei des gesundheitsministeriums
name und status der getesteten
kontaktpersonen hausbesuche
medikamentenvergabe alles ist hier
gespeichert für deutsche datenschützer
wäre das ein albtraum
ich habe früher genauso gedacht wie ihr
aber heute müssen wir wissen wer kubi
positiv ist und kontakt mit ihnen zu
vermeiden
in zeiten von corona ist die
datensicherheit nicht so wichtig dass
muss jeder verstehen
doktor changan zeigt uns eine app nur
für ärzte noch eine datenbank sie gibt
nur unsere personalausweisnummer nein
sofort kommt die meldung
sie gehören nicht zu den ersten impf
gruppen in den krankenhäusern wird als
erstes dieser impfstatus abgefragt nur
wer älter als 65 ist oder in einem
medizinischen beruf arbeitet darf
zurzeit geimpft werden hier im
krankenhaus im istanbuler bezirk st
apple bekommen pro tag 500 bis 600 leute
ihre spritze impfen wie am fließband mit
anmeldung manchmal aber auch ohne
ich konnte am telefon keinen termin
bekommen
mein mann wurde eben geimpft weil ich
auch geimpft werden wollte hat mir die
krankenschwester geholfen und gesagt
dann impfen wir sie halt gleich mit für
die termin buchung gibt es die
einheitliche nationale impfstelle phone
number 1 82 ich habe gestern abend um 8
uhr angerufen und sie haben hier für
meinen vater gleich wir heute einen
termin um 11.30 gegeben das ging total
schnell viele hatten am anfang bedenken
wegen des chinesischen impfstoffes
corona back er soll bis zu 90
prozentigen schutz bieten wurde im
eilverfahren zugelassen es musste alles
sehr schnell gehen wie so oft in der
türkei obwohl es einen monat später als
in deutschland losging sind mittlerweile
rund eine million menschen mehr geimpft
der chinesische impfstoff kann einfacher
gelagert werden als andere
es war eine entscheidung für die
schnellere lösung
ich denke dass die deutschen sich ihr
genau an die prozeduren halten und mehr
darauf achten dass alle richtlinien
eingehalten werden aber türkische ärzte
sind manchmal flexibel wie ergreifen bei
bedarf auch öfter selbst die initiative
und versuchen alles was irgendwie geht
möglich zu machen
wenn ich mich impfen lasse tut es auch
so die botschaft von präsident erdogan
mitte januar an sein volk maßnahmen die
in deutschland so einfach nicht
durchzusetzen wären kann der türkische
staatschef anordnen ohne wenn und aber
und was den kampf gegen die pandemie
angeht sind die meisten auch bereit ihm
dabei zu folgen
[Musik]